avant d'évoquer paquet et son impact
économique de s'intéresser aussi à la
concurrence entre centres commerciaux
avec le 40e anniversaire du centre paris
ouest à maurepas le point sur le chômage
vous le savez les chiffres au niveau
national sont mauvais plus de trois
millions de demandeurs d'emploi en
france et dans les yvelines c'est julie
rocha soares qui nous éclairent
120 c le nombre de demandeurs d'emplois
supplémentaires dans les yvelines fin
février par rapport à janvier 2013 ce
qui porte à cinquante six mille dix
personnes inscrites à pôle emploi en
catégorie à c'est à dire sans aucune
activité dans le département parmi les
plus touchés les seniors +15 8% sur un
an une donnée qui se traduit sur le
terrain laurence cousin divine info
jeunesse était l'invité du 7-8 ce mardi
elle note que les seniors postule de
plus en plus à des offres qui ne les
concernent pas directement on peut pas
fermer si vous voulez la diffusion des
offres après ben on a aimé un petit peu
en garde sur la pertinence en fait dû
par exemple de site pour quelqu'un qui
cherche un emploi à temps plein en cdi
et qui recherche qui a une formation
professionnelle vous laissez pas tout à
fait la même chose quant aux demandeurs
d'emploi de moins de 25 ans il
représente dans les yvelines huit mille
quarante personnes soit une baisse de -
2% sur un mois une première diminution
qui pourrait s'expliquer par le
dispositif des contrats d'avenir au
niveau national 15000 ont été signés
depuis sa mise en place en début d'année
par pôle emploi et les missions locales
alors que le nombre d'offres d'emploi
collectées dans le département ne s'est
levée en février qu 1 4060
à la chronique de l'éco une chronique de
l'éco gourmandin ce soit clair tout à
fait bon soir le 1er avril on fêtera
pâques donc pour tous les enfants c'est
synonyme de chasse aux oeufs en chocolat
aux adultes aussi voici certains adultes
12 dans cette chronique on va en
profiter pour parler du marché du
chocolat si tu nous période évidemment
importante en termes de ventes que ce
soit pour les chocolatiers mais aussi
les grandes surfaces de monde pourtant
bien différents alors comment se prépare
et organise ces ventes qu'est ce qui se
vend le plus c'est ce que la crise 1
pacte sur les ventes pour répondre à ces
questions nous recevons olivier roy d'or
qui artisan chocolatier à voisins le
bretonneux bourgeois qui nous a ramené
des échantillons
on aperçoit déjà à l'image et nicolas
mallet qui est chef des rayons épicerie
sucrée dans un supermarché donc à
meurent pas bonsoir pour un comme pour
l'autre c'est une période importante
voulzy pas préparé depuis longtemps qu
olivier roy d'heure à partir de quand
vous vous organisez en fête pâques pas
disons que le premier la première fois
c'est tout de suite après pâques on
débrief sur ce qui c'est sur ce qui
s'est passé donc là ça va intervenir
dans 10 6 d'ici quelques jours déjà voir
comment commencer s'est passé après bas
quelques quelques semaines après on va
commencer à dessiner ce qui ce qui va
être notre projet pour l'année d'après
on va faire quelques maquettes là on va
déjà se retrouver au mois de septembre
une fois que les maquettes sont prêtes
on va décider à peu près des des décors
que l'on va réaliser et puis ensuite on
va travailler en flux tendus pour que
les chocolats qu'on propose à la
clientèle soit des chocolats qu'ils
soient fabriqués depuis le moins de
temps possible c'est-à-dire claque
aujourd'hui on fabrique en flux tendu
tout les joies et dès
qu'il ya des produits qui sortent de la
chocolaterie qui est voisin et voilà les
pros le produit le plus vieux a aidé à
15 jours voilà donc le chocolat va
garder toutes ses toutes ses saveurs
parce que il vient d'être fait donc il
garde son arôme et garde sa longueur en
bouche il va voilà il est dans ces
meilleures conditions alors justement
pour organiser ses produits pour ce
faire le choix en fait un petit peu sur
les produits qu'ils allaient proposer
vous basez sur quoi et sur les ventes
passées sur un effet de mode alors on
bien sûr on va regarder les ventes
passées pour pas de sera des clients sur
les sur les produits qu'ils attendent le
plus on va essayer aussi de renouveler
la gamme de produits soit en cherchant
de nouvelles créations mais aussi en
changeant les décors en changeant les
couleurs en changeant la façon de
présenter ce que vous présenter ici
c'est des nouveautés juste voilà vous
avez un oeuf à 9 d'antenne à ma gauche
et puis là vous avez une barrière de
corail voilà deux présentations
différentes d'oeufs de pâques on y voit
des poissons c'est rapport au 1er avril
c'est bien
c'est conçu à partir de quand alors ça
fait un nom déjà où vous les aviez en
tête ses créations pour certaines oui
pour d'autres ça vient tout d'un coup
vous allez il ya des idées ça
ça vous arrive aussi comme ça et puis et
puis après il faut essayer de les faire
des maquettes pour voir si c'est
faisable réalisable s'il n'y a pas trop
de difficultés parce que c'est l'oeil
avant tout lorsque vous vendez le
chocolat quand on rentre dans une
chocolaterie c'est aussi l'oeil c'est
avant tout enfin nous on a la chance de
fabriquer sur place donc on a des
produits frais la première des choses
qui se passent quand vous rentrez c'est
l'odeur du chocolat mais ce que chez
nous a envahis de l'encenser lab la
boutique puisque la production est juste
derrière un petit peu avant vous avez la
vitrine avec les couleurs avec les
produits et voilà c'est le coup d'oeil
et c'est le le loader tout ça ça ça vous
fait forcément vous rentrez quand vous
êtes entré quand vous rentrez vous êtes
charmer alors nicolas mallet donc vous
ne fonctionne évidemment pas la même
façon il n'y a pas de production disant
je suis commerçant avant tout prix c'est
la grande différence du coût de votre
côté comment se prépare pâques c'est un
petit peu pareil c'est dès la fin de
pâques des bri évidemment de ce qui a
marché de ce qui n'a pas marché et après
la saison elle même va vraiment démarrer
au mois d'octobre novembre c'est le
moment où on va faire une réservation
auprès des fournisseurs donc on regarde
ce cas marché par marché l'année
dernière les nouveaux produits qui nous
propose
les nouvelles tendances qui ariz et donc
je vais faire des réservations
fournisseurs par fournisseurs dans le
but de respecter mon budget global que
j'ai défini par avant avec avec ma
direction soyez des produits qui sont
imposés ces syndicats lors c'est il ya
deux types de produits à les produits
qui vont être tracté donc qui vont se
retrouver dans l'est dans les catalogues
donc pendant la période de pâques donc
c'est l'âge et obligation de les faire
il y aura des prix imposés les offres
imposer les cagnottes des remises etc et
il ya des produits en plus que moi je
vais prendre pour compléter ma gamme
pourra avoir une gamme la plus large
possible je présente 300 400 références
à peu près donc une gamme beaucoup plus
large je les amène parfois des artisans
des artisans locaux moi je vois pas ce
que c'est relativement compliqué après
on travaille de très gros fournisseurs
comme kinder mille cas où lindt et on
travaille également des artisans de plus
petite échelle donc il reste toujours
sur une échelle plus grande que monsieur
donc des produits quand même un petit
peu industriel mais pour moi c'est
beaucoup de terre justement avec la
crypte et artisans parce que la grande
distribution il faut toujours établir
des contrats très précis on doit faire
des audits dans les entreprises pour
vérifier la qualité et ces écoutes où ça
coûte très cher et un magasin ne peut
pas se permettre de le payer santé
seront peut-être aussi de fraîcheur du
chocolat vous expliquez que vos
chocolats ont une durée courte ce qui
est différent cette fois le chocolat
industriel nouvelle assez le chocolat
qui vont grosse car les sauvegardes et
six mois et la deuxième contrainte qu'on
a c'est le monde qui va passer sur le
plateau mais j'ai un plateau sur lequel
vont passer plusieurs milliers de
personnes sur la journée et donc il me
faut des produits un minimum résistant
il me faut des produits que ça tout seul
emballé évidemment pour que
bah il soit pas sensible fait que les
gens les touches les manipulent et c'est
sur deux approches voilà très différente
même s'il reste autour du marché du
chocolat approche très différent
peut-être même aussi complémentaires
puisque l'un n'exclut pas l'autre ah oui
sa passion de chocolat on va s'en rendre
compte justement on s'est rendus donc
dans votre chocolaterie dans votre
hypermarché et on a fait un petit bilan
en fait sur le commerce des chocolats on
est allé à la rencontre des clients donc
avant de poursuivre je vous propose de
regarder le reportage que nous avons
réalisé
des poules d e ou encore des fraises du
chocolat sous toutes ses formes marie se
consacre à ses créations depuis un mois
et demi car à pâques la demande augmente
et si les classiques sont toujours les
plus prisées des créations un peu plus
original se sont glissés dans la vitrine
pour attirer plus de clients toujours
une nouvelle clientèle aussi pour le
regard quand tout ça est en vitrine du
coup les gens sont attirés à rentrer
dans la boutique
et cela semble fonctionner car cette
boutique ne connaît pas la crise ici les
consommateurs sont de vrais amateurs de
chocolat mais la qualité a un coût
si
les 3 éléphants face à ses futurs pour
limiter les dépenses brigitte ne réalise
dans ce magasin qu'une partie de ces
achats de pâques pour les enfants
j'achète plus tôt supermarché mais pour
les adultes jeu j'achète plus tôt en
chocolat tenaient une boulangerie parce
que je trouve que c'est une meilleure
qualité
effectivement au supermarché il ya foule
pour répondre à la demande un rayon
spécifique a été mise en place la
majorité des produits qu'on fait sur le
saisonnier sont des produits qu'on ne
sait pas le reste de l'année jusque là
c'est des moulages et les moulages on
n'en sait pas tout le reste de l'année
donc c'est vraiment une partie du rayon
à part qui est quasiment inexistante le
raid de l'année et qu'il a devient
extrêmement importante puisqu'on va
vendre entre 350 et 400 mille euros de
marchandise auprès 100 mille articles en
l'espace de moins de trois cent mille
ventes attendues car ce supermarché
observe en moyenne une stabilité des
dépenses quand cela concerne les enfants
mais dans les rayons la vie est plutôt
partagée
si on fait attention moi je me fixe 10
euros voilà un paquet duff et à un gros
voilà voilà ce qui fait à peu près une
sainte aux oignons sont faits plus dur
en menant 8 port-au-prince grosses qu'on
voit ce qu'est le mieux
ce qui est sûr c'est que tous les
enfants partiront lundi à la chasse aux
oeufs à pâques représente 5% de la
consommation annuelle de chocolat des
français nous sommes en jeu 7 kg par an
alors donc sur cet aspect budget en fait
des ménages vous ne ressentez vous pas
vraiment en fait la crise finalement
peut-être livre d'or la crise oui dans
le sens où les gens font plus attention
à ce qu'ils achètent mais non dans la
chocolaterie les gens viennent ici un
jour aussi souvent sont toujours autant
attirés par les parts des produits haut
de gamme alors c'est sûr qu'ils font
attention il ya des gens qui ne viennent
chez moi qu'à pâques ou qu'à noël à d
pour des grandes occasions mais parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils vont y rencontrer
des choses qui vont leur donner un
certain plaisir c'est vrai de grosses
périodes noël pâques oui ça représente
quelque part de votre chiffre d'affaires
sur l'année ça va représenter 10% du
chiffre d'affaires seulement seulement
pack seulement pas qui est vraiment pas
perial oui c'est une grosse panne pour
vous également finalement les chiffres
sont bons alors effectivement comme
c'est un marché très très orienté sur
lançant les parents même en situation un
peu difficile je choisisse de toujours
épargné leurs enfants et donc c'est un
marché relativement préservée on serait
beaucoup plus impactée par une période
de vacances ou dans la zone de
chalandise dans laquelle je suis il ya
pas mal de départs pendant les vacances
et on peut perdre 10 ou 15 % de la
clientèle ou bien
une météo défavorable de grosses pluies
au moment de dunes à l'ipa coup
évidemment
si on peut pas faire les chasses aux
oeufs à l'extérieur on achète un petit
peu moins si on fait ça en intérieur
peut-être un chiffre vous m'indiquer les
ventes sont très importantes photo à la
fin les ventes sont très très concentré
sur les derniers jours il ya quelques
personnes qui choisi d'anticiper donc
c'est pour ça qu'on installe les
chocolats trois semaines à l'avancé pour
permettre aux gens de découvrir un peu
la gamme mais on fait plus 40 % des
volumes sur les trois derniers jours
jeudi vendredi
ça nous sort de découvrir ailleurs et la
gamme s'exercer pour les parents qui
sont vraiment et qui vont aller manger à
présent et bien
ils ont déjà surmonté
faut mieux attendre le dernier moment
dans ces cas là il vaut mieux attendre
le dernier moment on parle aussi
beaucoup de chocolat au moment de noël
sur ces deux marchés entre noël et
pâques quels sont les moments les plus
pertinents important pour vous
chez moi le c2 marché assez différent
sur pas qu'on est sur une période qui
est vraiment très très courte donc comme
je vous le dis la plupart des volumes
sur une semaine et au total la campagne
dure trois semaines sur noël on est sur
deux mois sur noël on va en plus partir
sur des produits complémentaires on va
faire aussi du nougat du calisson etc et
on va être une gamme plus qui perdure
alors que pâques c'est vraiment lancé
l'enfant à votre m constat pour vous
constat que c'est plus long que pack wii
il à perdre été un peu plus longue c'est
pas aussi donc que que nicolas mais non
là c'est noël c'est différent mais no
est dans le sens où nous on propose
quelque chose qui va s'adresser à la
fois aux enfants et aux adultes là on va
retrouver à nouveau un espèce
d'engouement où les adultes vont rentrer
on dira oui ça c'est bien pour les
enfants ça commence déjà avec la saint
nicolas et puis après on va continuer
pour noël puisqu'on va proposer des
choses des des moulages typique pour les
enfants de chocolat chez aussi en plaine
et en plus c'est une belle année on
pouvait pas d'entre vous sait que c'est
toute l'année vous pouvez venir voir la
fabrication le matin et a aucun souci je
pense que c'est toujours aussi
intéressant merci à double aile de
clermont poursuit cette chronique de
l'écho